every now and then i get a friend or
family member saying that they're
interested in
buying some type of a business so this
wouldn't be about starting a business
but there might be an existing business
maybe it's a a convenience store or
maybe it's some type of
healthcare practice whatever it might be
and they say hey i'm going to buy this
from the existing owner and i think it's
going to be a great business and they'll
they'll often say it generates this much
money and i only have to put this much
in and it feels risk-free
and
what i tend to tell them and i don't
want to be one of these naysayer people
i say possibly
but what you always have to think about
is why are they selling it and sometimes
there's a good reason why they're
selling it maybe they're retiring and
they don't have someone to pass the
business on to and they see in you
kind of the the person that they would
love to see running that business going
forward that could be a a very
legitimate thing but oftentimes there
might be a situation where they might be
pumping up some of the numbers uh they
might be showing you the business in the
busy season or in the on the busy day
and so i wouldn't take especially if
it's a small business that doesn't have
auditing that doesn't have
really strict accounting practices
i would observe the business for a very
long period of time and i would take
your own data as to whether the numbers
you're hearing about are real and i also
wouldn't discount how much effort and
work the existing owners putting into it
and what happens to the business if
they're no longer there and so if all of
that works out and if it really does
make sense then yeah you might be on to
something